Humans are social creatures. We live together
in cities and crave being close to one another.
But is being social actually good for our
health?
Hey guys, Amy here on DNews.
Some not great news for single folk. According
to a 2002 review in the American Journal of
Sociology, uncoupled people have higher levels
of depression, anxiety, mood disorders, adjustment
problems, and demonstrate suicidal behaviour
more frequently than their coupled counterparts.
And it’s not just from crippling loneliness
that comes with spending night after night
on the couch with a growing number of cats.
Coupled people really do have a health advantage.
Like less pain. A 2010 study published in
PLoS ONE found that feelings of euphoria associated
with romantic love active the brain’s reward
system and reduces physical thermal pain.
The study had love-struck participants less
than nine months into a new relationship hold
a heat block. They were then asked to complete
three tasks: look at pictures of their significant
other, look at pictures of equally attractive
strangers, and complete a word-association
distraction task that has been shown to reduce
pain. Participants reported less pain with
both the partner pictures and the distraction
test, but only the partner pictures activated
areas of the brain associated with reward
systems suggesting love really is a drug-free
pain remedy.
Being in love — especially when you're nuts
about someone in the early phases of a relationship
— releases hormones in the brain that actually
make you happier. According to a 2010 study
by the University of Chicago and Northwestern
University, brains in relationships produce
cortisol, a stress hormone that regulates
and moderates the effects of stress on the
body. Romantic love also activates dopamine-rich
areas in the brain according to a 2005 study
in the Journal of Neurophysiology. These are
the parts of the brain associated with reward,
desire, addiction and euphoric states, so
basically all those things that make you feel
amazing.
Which is just a great thing overall. A 2000
study by the U.S. Bureau of the Census, found
that people in long-term relationships simply
live longer, and that’s even when adjusted
for socioeconomic factors.
So, great!
But kinda depressing for singles… good thing
friendships are also really important!
Our social inclinations mean that we support
each other in living the best lives we can,
helping us stick with healthy diets, encouraging
us to follow exercise routines, and also promoting
vital relaxation by just spending social time
together.
There have been dozens of studies that say
satisfying relationships with family and friends
have similar health benefits to being in love.
Strong friendships have been found to relieve
stress, which in turn contributes to healthy
coronary arteries, gut function, insulin regulation,
and immune system. Having a network of important
relationships can also make a difference in
the elderly, reducing the risk of dementia
in people over 75.
Like everything in our lives, the quality
of these relationships matter. The most positive,
healthy relationships and friendships will
have the best benefits for our health while
toxic friendships with negative people will
have the reverse effect. Some research has
even found that couples going through big
fights have lowered immune systems.
And it’s not just preventative medicine
that relationships are good for. People with
strong relationships are 50% more likely to
survive a life-threatening illness than people
with weaker ones. There’s nothing wrong
with leaning on friends if you’re going
through rough times. It might save your life.
So taking time to invest and maintain the
best relationships in your life isn’t just
good for your social life, it’s good for
your health for the rest of your life.
And if you’re thinking of letting that special
loved one know just how much you appreciate
how much they make your whole life better,
remember that Kay Jewelers is the number one
jewelry store in America.
So real friends are great!
But it turns out, Internet-friends are pretty
good for your health, too. We explore those
relationships a little more in this video
right here.
We’ll put a link in the description for
those of you on mobile.
How have good friends impacted your life?
Let us know in the comments below and don’t
forget to subscribe for more DNews every day
of the week.
How have good friends impacted your life?
Let us know in the comments below and keep
coming back to Test Tube for more DNews every
single day of the week.
How have good friends impacted your life?
Let us know on the Discovery News Facebook
page or on Twitter @DNews. And you can find
me; I’m @astvintagespace. Thanks for watching!